The minivan was designed with families in
mind, but it also revolutionized travel for
people in wheelchairs.
Retrofitted for wheelchair accessibility.
The minivan offers unprecedented mobility.
No need to wait for special wheelchair
transportation when there's a minivan in the
driveway. Convert a minivan and change a
life.
A wheelchair accessibility conversion offers
the convenience of a ride.
Any time from the outside, the van will look
no different, but inside, the modifications
will be major.
The total revamp starts with the removal of
the van's middle and third row seats.
They pull out the carpet and completely
strip the vehicle from the front seats to the
back. Underneath.
A technician saws off the exhaust system and
disassembles the rear suspension.
The entire undercarriage behind the engine
is about to be reconfigured to make way for a
new lowered floor.
The team also removes the 76 litre fuel
tank.
They'll replace it with one of the same
capacity to fit the new configuration.
They cut out a large section of floor and
relocate displaced wiring.
They're now ready to roll the new floor
framework into position below the vehicle.
This steel structure replaces the original
one and is strong enough to support the
additional weight of a wheelchair.
A motorized one can weigh as much as four
adults.
They slide the new steel floor into the
vehicle and lower it into the framework.
This new floor is significantly lower than
the one the van came with, and it increases
the wheelchair passengers headroom by 30 to
40cm.
After installing the new fuel tank,
suspension and exhaust systems, they returned
to the interior.
A technician fits and bonds carpet under
padding to the van.
He installs the carpet and clamps it while
the adhesive cures.
With the back of the van rebuilt and
carpeted, they now ready the wheelchair ramp.
A technician applies a gritty material with
an adhesive backing.
He simply presses it to the ramp and smooths
out any air bubbles.
This gritty material will provide a slip
resistant surface for the wheelchair to move
across. He attaches a handle and installs
two cable assemblies to connect the handle to
the ramp latches.
He attaches a return spring to the handle
assembly.
He turns the handle and tests the latches to
confirm that the mechanisms function
properly. The team then links the wheelchair
ramp to the new floor with a long
hinge. They install stainless steel trim
over the hinge to protect it and also connect
the counterbalance cables to the ramp.
Hidden springs at the end of the cables
provide tension to significantly lighten the
load for the operator.
The ramp weighs 60kg, but the operator ends
up lifting just seven kilograms of that due
to the spring loaded tension.
They reinstall the interior plastic panels
and repurposed the original second row seat
belts. As they finish up inside, an employee
puts the company name on the door of the
vehicle. The wheelchair converted van is now
ready for a test drive.
The operator unfolds the ramp.
He folds away the new seats to make way for
the wheelchair.
He extends the tie down belts and attaches
them to the wheelchair.
He wheels the passenger into the van, locks
the wheelchair brakes, and ties the chair to
the floor. There are standard seatbelts to
fasten and then it's time to sit
back and enjoy the ride.
Ensconced in the converted minivan, the
limited mobility individual can now
experience the freedom of the road.
Bowls have existed for thousands of years.
Very early bowls used to serve food or
drink.
Have been found in China, ancient Greece,
and in certain North American cultures.
Modern bowls can be made from a variety of
materials such as ceramic, plastic, metal and
wood. Wood bowls come in many shapes and
sizes.
Many different kinds of wood are used to
make bowls such as rubber wood and teak.
Acacia is also a type of wood used to make
bowls.
Workers cut flat planks of acacia using a
large circular saw.
The acacia was cut a few days ago in nearby
plantations.
Planks are cut to thicknesses required for
bowl production and pre dried on pallets
spaced apart for better air circulation.
Using a table, saw a worker cuts the wood
planks.
Now kiln dried into pieces long enough to
make the bowl wall.
Another worker uses a tilted table saw to
cut the wood into shapes resembling a cone.
Drying the wood eliminates water that might
cause cracking later on.
A worker trims the pieces, giving them the
angle they need so the staves can be rounded
later on. Another worker smooths the rough
side of the staves with a spinning cutter.
This also helps shape the wood pieces.
Another employee lines up the staves on a
table before applying glue.
She spreads a wood bonding glue onto the
sides of the staves.
Once they're thoroughly covered with glue,
she begins assembling the bowl by sticking
the sides together.
She assembles a few pieces at a time,
handing them to another worker who arranges
the bowl shape by leaning the staves against
a centerpiece.
They continue the process until all the
staves are in place.
Then they'll squeeze the staves tightly
together.
They stretch elastic bands around the
outside of the eventual bowl.
The elastics held in place by a steel ring
squeeze the staves firmly against each other.
With a hammer.
She lightly taps the staves into place,
making sure they are flush against each
other. She turns the bowl over to make sure
none of the staves around the top rim are
sticking out too far.
She then leaves the bowl to dry about five
hours later.
They remove the elastics and again leave the
bowl to harden for a full day.
A template is attached to the eventual bowl
in order to cut a circular opening for the
bottom piece. The template serves as a guide
during the cutting process.
A worker moves the bowl around, allowing the
cutter to create a perfectly sized hole for
the bottom section of the bowl, which is
made of the same kind of wood, in this case,
acacia. A worker applies glue to the edges
of the bottom hole.
And to the outer edge of the round piece
that goes in the bottom of the bowl.
He inserts the bottom plate and uses a
hammer to force it firmly into place.
After another day of hardening, a worker
places the bowl in a lathe with a variety of
knives. He begins shaving off the wood.
He starts on the inside wall of the bowl.
Then he shaves the outside of the bowl,
gradually giving it shape.
He then uses sandpaper to smooth the surface
of the bowl.
Another worker then uses a lathe to sand the
surface of the bowl.
He makes the surface as fine as possible.
He must have a keen eye for detail in order
to make the bowl surface perfect.
A worker sprays a foodstuff varnish onto the
surface of the bowl.
Several layers are applied with drying and
polishing after each one.
If required.
A stain is also applied.
They place a sticker identifying the
manufacturer on the bottom of the bowl.
A worker then packages the wood bowl with
the bowl secure.
The only thing tossed about will be the
ingredients you put in it.